really
what's a fool Parkin what's up fool we
heard the worse off for podcast with Rio
Torres Lisa what's up fool Chile right
here just chilling man we're talking
about a lot of sure that you guys don't
watch like shows on FX like they spent
three seasons of Fargo and who've seen
it I've seen them all right now I'm
going through season two you know I like
see the three though
that's it into right the Wahlburgers the
one with a guy from from that show from
that show that I never watched to either
he was like a doctor or I don't know
what he was the closer the fixer he was
in a show with Emery Donovan Emma Emma
Stone Emma Emily Emily Blunt what she
had a series before their face well
woman who look like Emily Blunt she's a
woman in Sicario yes he cardio yeah I
don't know he's in the 70s one yeah he
played the brother but the world what
are the mountain guys there was a beard
and everything oh yeah the middle one
the one with the teeth when I took over
yeah yeah he's in a lot of stuff he's in
um always in so many things
yeah he was good man Godfrey's but I
will their names your Fargo your hearts
the Gerhardt's yeah yeah
hell yeah IDO the greatest Jean smart
from designing woman
so we're like it okay yeah here static
I'm good you what's up boo what's up boo
this week this week I made a spotlight
29 February 2nd for every first
everybody said yeah I think I saw it
sold out sold out and I'm coming to
Alabama or Mississippi you're coming to
Alabama in two weeks I have dates coming
but I'm looking at Fargo stuff forget
the Fargo stuff give you a cough
let me clear my throat all that t-shirt
t-shirt is black mm I want to say 2013 I
got them over at t-shirts tubes good
it's all worn out it's a I got one man
that's pretty old I still have it the
Playboy one I bought at the airport
what's all this [ __ ] yeah fully used to
wear that's it that's it
I could tell all because uh she's fading
you know and the strings are coming
loose the woman also dead - this morning
she will know dead - they gotta go - boy
if you don't like needles you know get
no shots she give you that if you need a
Venice Dennis they don't use any
painkillers and [ __ ] right
those people rather give a real hot
charcoal brew and they break it over to
put on your mouth you start brushing I
have some that toothbrush toothpaste
right now
it's like some weird mint chocolate
brown it's black does it work
I like the way did you don't have that
aftertaste dawg it looks like [ __ ]
though it'll pull out any toxins like I
feel cleaner dog I'm not gonna lie to
you really good
I do do I want the imagine burn a flour
tortilla scoop it on your mouth but you
know what yeah yeah listen this you know
what when you were we were talking to
what's-her-face
Martin's ex about that and her mom was
paisa lady in denial okay yeah did you
lose but she knew all these like I
always thought of his girlfriend it's
very Americanized you know very you know
for having a mother who was so we're
good double ages something yeah she just
hide it I guess except when she was with
you guys and she we come out you know
but she I was talking about charcoal for
food poisoning and stomach flu and all
that stuff because if you take charcoal
tablets it goes away not like regular to
charcoal from the bag right right now
there are charcoal councils and it is
charcoal the cool roundup it is charcoal
that's grown it's charcoal that so
fighting for yeah that's cool right yeah
unprocessed cold but charcoal comes from
that but it's charcoal is coal has a
property in it that helps clean that
helps purify and a lot of water
purifiers have charcoal in the or and a
lot of scent you know older purifiers
and things in the filters yes and the
fish filter to it has charcoal that's
graphite isn't it is the pencils but I
know you taught the little pieces of
charcoal that you used to draw wood my
hair anyway so we were talking about
charcoal and and I said it'll stop your
food poisoning they take a couple
capsules which is dark a spice that
charcoal dark are they would never be
like how if you put him in jail huh who
would steal here we cooking rice dog by
himself and then I every time hoping the
pot of rice try them on some guy used to
work with man he took he's today with
our drew street and now
because I'm it needs a bag on him I
require he caught up with charcoal goes
dark did that sorry but you like Erik
Estrada dark you know I'm here to be
with us by the rice we had this big old
kennel like this you working for your
Shino yeah and he will open it up bro
and that would be right for the biggest
Ebro a purpose that didn't look at us
cleaning that is poor
I guess dog food no that's a big carry
just stay away from because I burn right
there in front of it nice tdawg clean up
words did I ever say lit that's what you
like charcoal so we still a car with
charcoal after that it was that nasty
food is a true Chicano carucha oh my god
that fool what was like one of those
cholos bro that was drilling like a
hardcore cholo but here from nowhere he
like he from nowhere like he ain't got
no hood but he's still like be with
chawla Z but him from nowhere there was
Gilbert's my culture homes and you
talking exactly that they all like dude
I forgot show up to work bro with like
the tree stump nice pants and some shiny
a Stacy Adams and one but to go walking
are hard and he's like like he's walking
like in a scene of American me about to
watch a movie and get stabbed
but he's gonna work at understand yeah
so like like there's no lockers to
change the wrong are you serious how is
it then there's changing a bathroom you
guys have to change in the bathroom yeah
so what rates work bro ah there's no you
don't have a wreck it is like [ __ ] a
very surly you put a co-ed lockers a
little stereo so I'm ready to work or
you are you're a clean floor with a
backpack so what the [ __ ] was this for
doing taking this time
this fool you still fo to go get ice
he'll go to every food stand talking to
people problem by the way he hoped he
ever did like I'll think he ever did 20
minutes a word the whole time I saw him
there bro
that fool take off bro walking like this
are hard every job you put him in he
look like a cholo that was baking it dog
now you give that full boob he then he
started with a brew ball hard a kindly
real alrighty then I for be like and he
knew everybody broke what's up i ricotta
for the lie it's a metro politician he's
telling like April don't you know that
dude over there from Echo Park
they cut a fool Cobra she used to work
over here it's all souvenirs just like
man he's like my primo homie he's like
like my cousin homie yeah man we need to
go way back I had a lady and a job bro
and then dude yo shoe like the 235 post
with pattern hickeys bro
like dark was brutally tortured no mom I
don't does but this was an escape me
honey
like if someone if he knew like somebody
died Oreo somebody's birthday they just
say he was up your birthday he'll go run
although all the stands bro collecting
donations for you for your birthday so
you get some cash but you never got all
the cash he took a cut of course he's
did collection plate because first of
all you didn't know they was doing that
in how did Katherine catch him in alive
oh here we go he said I'm so yeah but
you don't bury yeah I don't bury us Bobo
sister yeah Marianne April you know me
me yes I know that girl yeah yeah I have
to go over there
then it ever goes they broke you know
this building Claudia and you go to
Claudia Claudia Wooding
quit your yeah I don't you [ __ ] like
my sister stupid mr. fully knows
everybody that sound cool huh you like I
realize that's funny
we ain't badgers unique way your quail
or
what was here when his girlfriend broke
up uh-huh and they have it they're being
broken up he he started collecting his
money at her Bob deities I first started
collection for her mommy funeral
services are yeah
you want to bury her we don't want it
burn her up but it was funny though over
the big ass car so it's a homewrecker
sanity and your leave stuff to go ahead
if you want to and did he collect money
talk bank and everybody knew that fool
that fool talked to everybody but I was
a prohibited in the pocket Dodger dugout
dogs with a push broom doing something
wrong or partaking waters a grass it
trying to get out close he got it
everywhere for really in the whole
little girl organization and he always
about like cologne address Flores how
would that feel look when he left word
about the same or what for the same no
suede homie the last time I saw a fool
he was a security guard software and bro
his pants were too big dog that jackie
was too big and here all like this hold
me like still trying to be styled like
top flight security guard like he made
that jacket look like like one of those
cholo Jackie's or the old school was
like they ever the line yeah yeah every
sure he had every penalty to that she's
the whole like [ __ ] outfit on now you
hit him what do you do what did he do
back in the day when you hit him up
the 90s right 99 will you from ho be
hateful no we're hoping this is just a
lifestyle that I probably what he said
dude it's just a lifestyle for me I just
like tasty because I represent me cool
to them
shut the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] you pick
everything I know after 30 year of it
that I know how but whatever other chick
that he's dated they're from somewhere
right different neighborhoods right
that's what they have a pocket cold bro
let's go the finger it was like a round
one you put your finger in it in the
middle finger and you run way back but
this [ __ ] you how come people never call
[ __ ] [ __ ] dawg I don't know
people don't want to come why don't they
let it go on man it's be bean PC though
you don't want any problems just
whatever you go talk to you when you go
home this is like I to us not me and
Ivan bro we knew because we knew he was
lying Don hey bro come over here trying
to help or a beer too many thong do you
want to be a trend every time the only
way he would look like if you say it's a
like you'll see oh dude outside dude
outside doing stuff right well a burger
you'll be so high it'll be a pervert and
then easy on the freeway amber to your
ass Anika four five five five
and I'd be like damn my car - Yoda
I'll get paranoid about what kind of car
do I have since I'm still able to play
the wrong card I start looking at your
ass dog calling the CHP yeah man
you're crying your car by yourself yeah
pulled over in his bald I was thinking
about Taylor because I'm kind of barley
yesterday you know it was just a little
sad but I remember body in my car but
I'll see whether the police would've
pulled me over man
oh you were ball you driving oh yeah uh
I'll barley drive it one time and I'm
putting the cop pulled me over II pulled
over ma'am good would you like a little
bit of like saliva and like a little
mucus coming in with it the worst thing
your Lord
good everything that's why I dude I
don't know man I used to trip out
fooling like cuz that you were sober
when I met your ass dog and he started
getting [ __ ] up I just like cuz I
never I tripped out when fools would cry
when they would get drunk like sometimes
as a little kid there was every now
again a full start crying and then like
it'll turn into somebody's like calming
them down okay and then you'll try to
fight somebody it was like I thought
drinking was just like laughing [ __ ]
for most normal people like I remember
like people just like at a drop of a hat
but like the people that like I have an
uncle fool second uncle this
[ __ ] gets [ __ ] drunk dude
like coming home coughing out blood like
throwing the [ __ ] couch through the
[ __ ] living room like [ __ ] up dog I
would ship out on that I thought I was
all about good times but you know I
didn't want to intervene
like [ __ ] some fools are different you
know you pull over and [ __ ]
I pulled over and just [ __ ] let it
out dog or give you your sometimes
you're at your house and you let it down
yeah I've cried in front of my mom and
she can't even count the times I've
cried in my car ya know I've quite a lot
like you just but I think that's a
cleansing when you cry like that you
live it it's an equivalent to me kind of
like roomies dog like see crying you
need to do it also Philippe it comes
from the background where you know
you're told to keep it in and you don't
cry and we would always make fun of each
other like when we cried odd you it's
like you know kind of picking on you too
but you have to he's actually not
supposed to defy his parents like not
allowed to and that's so dangerous it's
gonna come out going to quite a Bambi
yeah remember Isaac when he cried it
where the wild things are when they
floated away yeah he's like no it was
just the screen was bright he was like
seven he didn't want us to know yeah but
just painful [ __ ] that happened - yeah
man I think it's a cleansing though when
you cry whatever you know oh yeah how
the cop reacted me pullo you cry well a
lot of girls to get out of tickets I
used to try try to joke where this girl
told me this trick I know she's got
pulled over twice [ __ ] up and she
cried to the cops and they let her go
the second time he's all you just gotta
give me your number and she's dead well
I said I try to do the same thing but
the cop told me yeah but you're gonna
have to blow me [ __ ] all the
time for the [ __ ] but ya dog getting
away with it you can shoot my war bro
oh yeah like that Chief of Police bro
for New York uh-huh [ __ ] our sister
done you better work like some Mexicans
yeah
she told our detectives because they
were looking for some sexual predator
how much you are to go out there do your
job and work like Mexicans and then she
said those those they taught me for
Saturday and they said like to have the
the the force was Hispanic right
Dominican and Puerto Ricans yeah and one
guy was married to a Mexican the rest of
them white should probably look at the
white fools go don't be snitching or how
about the she probably left a lot of
words out of the best beach like she
final advantage buddy she probably told
them you got to work like Mexicans you
know but she probably what to say cuz
y'all been working that black people and
then cut that off oh hell yeah and you
and you guys get paid what the [ __ ] well
yeah and then the part about snitches
you probably saw wipers adobe snitch
don't be snitch on me like white people
see but the only focus on the mask in
part oh yeah I'm looking at a white dude
I bet you that Chief of Police that
woman that woman she's her some racist
[ __ ] though oh well that I think she
came up and she became an authority
figure and then people right dude [ __ ]
this black [ __ ] but it's funny though
how happen with her how I was different
when a woman seasons yeah that's one
again a black man saying it even like a
like a white chick saying I think it's
the the woman factor cuz I say what
gender those guys were in that force
I bet you the majority of them are man
dog cuz they also said she collected
it's funny that you brought up the thing
about cuz I read the whole article and
she collected money for a birthday party
and she never had the birthday party and
then she was getting investigated by
internal affairs that and then she gave
the money back
so just Ana but we're just how much was
the chief of police lady said and I'm
just you know cuz also she's a woman and
he had the biggest thing when a woman
say that yeah she could knows a
corruption upward cuz that would have
been a black man sayin I'm or even a
Mexican man or asian man lady man it
wouldn't have been as hardcore as bad as
they're coming out of her yeah she just
got the bad luck of the draw I don't
think she just had she'd have the the
people behind it all
are the people though should I kept that
money bro
but I bet she came up corrupt you think
the Dominicans of Puerto Ricans were
offended that she didn't say hey what
the [ __ ] he's talking about scam artists
that fool fool the fire festival do we
see that clip at Steve's right well
what's the name plate a little bit of it
yeah and then uh so why are the fire F
why are you yeah the thing is well it's
called fire I think the one on Netflix
and then the other one is called fire
fraud I think that's the vice one or the
Netflix is a vice one Netflix is the
vice one and then the other one is it's
basically people it's two different
perspectives of people who worked with
McFarland and Hulu what she was just
saying Hulu paid Emma was just saying
that Hulu paid a hundred thousand to
that guy MacFarlane to get the interview
that's why he was in that one and so
he's been paid he got them for a hundred
thousand so the whole documentary start
off with a guy they ever come it makes
an app an app that we could all that we
could all like if I were a higher I want
a higher LL Cool J I could hire through
the app like the app so that's how he
made his first money because he talks
about the app that that he wanted to
start with ja Rule as the face of it
right so for example you can go and say
hey I want maroon 5 to play my bar
mitzvah or whatever and you make an
offer to maroon 5 now maroon 5 has to be
on it though this is another thing I
don't know anybody who's going to forgo
their agent and go directly to somebody
who wants to book you for a [ __ ]
birthday party bad idea already you know
unless you're rich enough you know maybe
if you're but if you're rich enough
you'll go through their age
directly to them like people who email
you show up at my daughter's King say
this forward from all that right
nonsense buh-buh-buh full of working on
the app difficult even crazy right
vehicle cash now to raise money for the
app it was a really money for the app
because you know what we're gonna have a
better festival then Burning Man better
than all these fellas all that [ __ ] so
this will go all the way to Norman Kaye
island where Pablo Escobar was shipping
coke from number we're gonna have the
best of all here right so you know bro
there's no [ __ ] plumbing in that
island there's no [ __ ] sewer system
you know it can't it can't hold more
than 7,000 people at more than Island so
it all fall apart bro they have no money
it falls a far apart first though
because the guy who had the who owned
the island said you can use it for
whatever fee but you can't mention that
it was Pablo Escobar's cuz that's not a
cool thing over there was that gonna be
his hook and that's that was the first
thing and they're probably their first
post about social media post and so they
said you can't use the island so they
kicked him out they kicked him out of
they said you can't have the festival
here so he then he was island shopping
my customs and stuff right yeah they
brought in bottled water and customer
holding it for 1.5 million truckloads of
water so this is do this gay guys there
right a partner older dude bro
older dude it was like an event
coordinator the event coordinator he
goes bad
you dance with table peaceful he's right
here telling a story like this when it
came to the point where I had to take
one for the team not even knowing if the
lieutenant's gay he's gay so second of
all would you do
never have yeah we should do while I am
gone with a shitload of mouthwash first
and I hate dr. lieutenant you're lying
yeah he said I was in the car stop
believing us on my way to do the month
and he went over there
[Laughter]
he looks like Tom dreesen exactly Toby's
new clothes new class the older man you
know he said imagine my 30 year career
ending like this like that's what that's
my final job at that age that's event
coordinator of the [ __ ] century yeah
maybe he'll get some work at it but yeah
so basically they owe everybody their
rent debt it just falls apart I never
hit the water back they got the water
released the thing is you know what they
bought two million dollars of booze
they got two million dollars for the
booze and the duty on that in the
Bahamas is 45% they owed $900,000 in
forecast any of this [ __ ] then no no and
what they did forecast he didn't have
money for anyway he was hoping for
ticket sales to pay for that stuff and
that's a bad situation you know you have
to have money in front credit and
promises he goes
you do this three months what the [ __ ]
yeah a year and a half three months bro
and it's in Bahamas but it's in the
Bahamas unpopulated not very populated
island so there's no infrastructure
anyway and so they're lying out in the
desert yeah Coachella prices bro like
you could be on a yacht yeah young
package right yeah beachfront villa you
could have your own weight or else none
of the stuff but what's crazy people pay
ya Jenner and the Jenner got paid two
hundred fifty thousand dollars for one
Instagram post and she wasn't even
showing up she wasn't even going to this
party she just was mentioning it can't
you do it for 250 for the full podcast
yeah but nobody everybody started
pulling out I think blink-182 is the
first to pull out and I was like a day
before the show because they just
probably couldn't get an answer deposits
weren't being paid
people weren't getting the answer they
needed on whether the stage and the
lighting was gonna be a to their
specifications these are headlining
bands you have to have lighting a
certain way sound a certain way in the
stage of rob hardcore yeah she's a white
chick tanning floating on a matches in
the water oh yeah that's funny cuz they
ended up having like air mattresses in
tents and there was a deluge of water
the day before it was a monsoon rain and
so yeah the regatta on the other Island
was happening that same weekend so there
was there were nowhere to put these
people anyway but this guy which just
got in way over his head he didn't have
enough money to have the festival he
thought that having the festival is
gonna raise money for the app and you
forget about the app so he never made
yet no nobody nobody's gonna use that
app anyway what happened ja rule ja Rule
is in 17 lawsuits I think there's a meme
of him bro like with his face only being
chased by jungle
yeah they had no food no water nothing
these people and they they ripped off a
bunch of people who did work in the
Bahamas these people are poor people who
thought they were gonna make some money
building stuff and helping out 18-hour
days look the fake Raul Julia jr. huh
something something similar to that
happen to me what happened not to me but
I was I was bought to the body but I was
booked to do a show in Rocky Point what
the peñasco so after the hurricane or
something over there okay Julio told me
and Ernie G Coolio headlining okay and
they had like a bunch of other bands or
going up before them right festival the
festival three days two-day festival
weekend and put on a Rocky Point
Mexico Puerto peñasco Julio me doing
stand-up comedy bro anyways the day of
the event they these guys who did the
show forgot to bribe the right people in
Mexico Pro or pay off people or say or
were they told you you're gonna pay us
right now they said [ __ ] you you know
probably and if they know you can't do
that to a guy in Mexico show your [ __ ]
downtown so they'll cut the electricity
off so they're now the the day of the
event there was a bar next door he I
said that he was gonna be closed like
Tori needs bands right but then
something happened was he thought they
were gonna get help
then they let him sell beer inside the
event or whatever happened he didn't
want him so this point of having his bar
opened it's a big-ass bar to free
admission for all three days so nobody
went everybody went over there for free
admission and had free drinks DJ music
and they $35 $40 to see Coolio bro in
what happened it was emptier what was
emptier than empty did Coolio perform
roll there was two fans there for me you
guys perform boy
perform after Coulee enrollment but when
I perform when I went up on stage it was
a track a tryout they were the state
band you know like abroad truck with no
background when I was on stage I would
they were taking down everything bro
I'm performing to the workers I've done
a show like that before on a stake bed
and Brawley dog our posture did the
windmill dog oh my god I forgot about
that cut that little foot bro are we
gonna get paid bro
he said that broth on my lab on the way
home brew with that fool look back lose
like pasta boxes of flyers bro of that
show it's always when you have an FBI
show you have a lot of fliers left which
I get in through Mexico crossing from
Phoenix or whatever town it is a Mexico
to get to other so I resort up Mexican
border wrong photos over we had truck of
sound equipment all that right guys came
with the promoter yeah tip that what you
guys drove together no bro Lavery
brother was killed natural how many days
full performance one night I'm gonna
leave with him right but no three nights
right haha there was no show I was there
for three nights no show so that I was
probably earful I was there with a
promoter and all the sound equipment and
annoying another annoying [ __ ] yeah
so we got though we get to the border
dude I guess I don't know I don't know
how basic in customs are they what they
want bribes to I don't think they wanna
dude they serve everything and you guys
get a pay some money to get back seeding
as well I'm gonna come over
according to Mexico you should be
worried about that DVD you should be
worried about the [ __ ] that leaving
Mexico just worrying about Talent broad
I didn't wanna [ __ ] around broad these
guys were all talking [ __ ] you know
black guy never been to Mexico do the
some of these artists I shut the [ __ ] up
bro oh yeah that's what I speak he spare
immediately well I never seen Mexican
soldiers dressed in blue and they all
had ak-47 our m16 and their what y'all
do like 18 years old they're the ones
when we went through customs to try to
get in and we were waiting out there
everybody was dressed like that - they
all had m16 well they do but ready bro
and every time bad deal only they thing
kind of um chop us yeah they look like
they're bored and ready to use those
guns because there's nowhere to use them
right there like and then some of them
just walking around [ __ ] with people
with the of us you know what is already
well [ __ ] they can do Dawg you're in
their country though that's your
different laws I felt like it took a
deep roll there do you don't have you
there for eight hours and they're all
they're gonna do is just take cash from
you I don't know but I guess you didn't
have cash for none of this stuff over
there were no permits on the way it was
a conference with a music show called
flagel when we bent damn
the fuego federal relation to fire back
so happy it was about everybody had a
man hey you think Coolio got ripped off
too
he performed oh I bet he got a deposit
oh he did perform before didn't know my
powers bro we got back you wrote me a
check for $700 or to go catch the share
Wells Fargo you never pursued any action
against ever was the guy a Mexican guy
or somebody here in the famous days it
was a guy so happy and Arizona but they
have done shows before they probably
like their ass yeah but [ __ ] that
promise you money that's agreement but I
got booked by not to being promoted by
his brother goes I'll bring you along
whatever but I got work I never signed
okok so you know right before they're
having grand they were asked but yeah do
so first of all there's no rooms we get
the roaches like a documentary there's
no rooms for you guys or anybody just
rule the rooms right but but they're all
like man it was like you kick these
doors down bro right when you grew up in
the hood you were thinking about
breaking into [ __ ] or how well just do
this Lambo is a criminal state of mind
yeah you said that when we went to solve
a solving with all these Christmas trees
in the most beautiful beautiful idyllic
Christmas town and then nobody's around
and we're looking at all the Christmas
lights and all the Christmas trees in
town and we're on mushrooms right I
think right yeah yeah and then it's like
man I could just I just push this door
in I could get in here to the store and
it's like there's no gates on anything
look like a green house it was all glass
this was gated damn
oh and never telecoil but about it was
all your mind went there like that we
were to go eat I remember I want to go
eat in that town and Astro soda and here
too in a plastic bag gross in a straw oh
the two ice that's called tiempo
what the [ __ ] Shirley with a battle with
the deposit deposit yeah yeah yeah you
give them that [ __ ] back there give you
another one do you have to pay for it so
bad anymore it's really like better
recycling than we do here in this
country you know it's how we used to do
it yeah
now they got plastic [ __ ] - so the hotel
hotel blow like the owner had a
he goes in all the rooms you guys who
remember the day of like Robin Hood they
used to have cats and the cats would go
inside the hunts and open the doors the
levers cats [ __ ] useless fools and
stealing dog in a cab probably what you
would tell me the head says the the word
cat burglar the term raccoons - cuz he
got five digits yeah
Hussein said what I won't big pocket it
was honey
casteau car keys they do cats can do
some question dude cats cats they wait
they could kill a bug like this is one
nail yeah one now like Pierce is it
I think that's ripping a pom apart -
like they do like rats get the organs
and then just rip it up and they just
won't have fun with it yeah yeah
the rules are so bad
like what like concrete floors in the
living room like [ __ ] like Cambodia in
architecture huh so what's up don't love
to do it they would love to do at the
after what you call day I thought they
are they go there was no show but but
they do have everybody there but nobody
will really perform everybody performing
- nobody bro
really dude so the first day do you mean
pull out the first day anyway they would
know how to take his boy and that's a
worse when it shows big and there's only
a couple people because it's really
alekhya was a rodeo that a roadie with
no audience and it was like I never look
a rap group called Negro League hip like
a Warriors MC satchel page you'll see
Ricky Robinson and who else came out of
the Negro Leagues it was badass
I don't know I just remember the whole
central place where a lot of food Pedro
Guerrero hey dine out so what the [ __ ]
happened dog what the hey the [ __ ] ER
DG performed I know who can do shoot
that an audience buddy
I remember that we went to the bar and I
saw this black dude peen bro like he
started peeing on a side of the bar all
loaded and one of those they had a
little Mexican security guard just walk
around with broomsticks little bit of
rope rope little billy club a billy club
and then like he's [ __ ] like baggy as
parents like they don't even tell me I'm
right and like what el security girl
they ask what size you are
put it away what's the lowest or I put
it on no Taylor and then like a shitty
ass hat so then I pull down that way
like what's happening with Hanford's
right like stop placed kind of they come
at a no don't do that here in a foot
post oh yes one more time right kind of
thing in the Second World War was a Polk
bro like a like a pole with a stick you
don't know they never have whoo hell
does take another woman behind him or
somebody out or right in the back yeah
bro again three warriors already tied
her to a stick they pushed our fool out
and they started [ __ ] him up bro he's
trying to fight back there being a
[ __ ] ass
and then these scariest [ __ ] I ever see
you broke these cops show up I wonder
where Penn like Lisa let's check her
pants okay and a code boy that Detective
probably in a Volkswagen dog to be a
Volkswagen car
Volkswagens do back in the day like what
he's getting PETA by fluffy bro hey [ __ ]
him and then his friend is there
recording the whole thing the battle
trend yeah time to blow homie homie what
are you doing dog how long is this gonna
take fur to find a VCR for that [ __ ] you
just take the tape save the tape use
that camera as his bail they were
beating us that in the car because he'll
be like he didn't want to go to jail and
now that would it was just like cops
doing that [ __ ] to a cops he's a real
cop soda bro they were just [ __ ] him
up they're gonna be the - all the way to
jail and it's gonna take money to get
that fall out of jail yeah I'll do it
not pee in the bar I've seen that do you
stop the [ __ ] out bloody in on
Revolution in 1996 by military fools
they're beating the [ __ ] out of this
dude and there was a Latino chick with a
brother dog and the brother got live
with the people at the club we were at
one of those clubs like a strip club
that we were 18 could drink over there
all that [ __ ] I went with Fraker the
mouse everybody and dude that fool got
crazy with them and they beat his ass in
the street and this girl started trying
to stop it and should they beat the [ __ ]
out of her to go look like mega [ __ ]
up like welcome to Tijuana like lift
almost dead looking you don't mess
around bro in any country how'd it look
to you guys what you guys would this
last time you look still dangerous TJ
hell no no it was crowded in New York
ish you know in certain parts where we
were staying
[Music]
yeah a little gastro pub that we went to
nice yeah they were playing some
musicians are playing they had a vegan
restaurant on the beach there and place
was cool so man what's up sorry man it
was just I thought I got kidnapped the
hotel of the repetition of people that
fire that
and all up or forward I like it yeah the
problem was that okay so he's trying to
have this festival to pay for the app
but then the festival ends up costing a
ton of money which I don't know why he
didn't predict that but he thought he
could sell enough tickets to pay for
this festival and then the more of the
profit from it would be to pay for this
app right but he gets so bogged down in
debt from this festival with costs he
didn't expect that he it the festival
just never happens well the people show
up but like it as far as like an
attendance I don't know it was a few
thousand I think it was supposed to be
like twenty thousand was the ad was
everything yeah and it was like a
beautiful it had models and slow motion
and everybody's glowing so they've got a
lot of influencers like kendall Jenner
and some other people just post about it
and build a hype people with 21.5
million yeah so that was posting and
then they got a everybody but the thing
is the influencer is also kendall Jenner
wasn't coming but they're like that
level we're getting paid as well if they
went to the festival they would get paid
with a room a villa a nice place for
free like that was their incentive to go
to get to go there is to get this free
villa and enjoy the festival and they'd
post about it and everything but they're
losing money on those because not enough
other people were buying villas you know
renting villas and stuff they were
wanting the tents or staying somewhere
else
yeah so they were like you know nine
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars
but we can pass there some most of
cheapest but they weren't making enough
because though all those tickets were
being sold so then he's like well we'll
just make them sold out so all they can
do is buy the premium
probably like a little attitude and what
didn't have happened with this fool he's
in jail right would you jail and he got
build out another scam your life buddy
he started scam while he was out on bail
and then they put him in again and he's
in who's little poorer the only idiots
right I have a hundred Hamilton tickets
per cell
you know that should be sold out for a
whole year yeah he sold tickets on the
side to raise money too but tickets that
didn't exist he's fraud he's defrauding
people but then what happened was Oh let
Peter Peter play Paul right yeah but
then he makes my stupid mistakes cuz he
would try to sell Hamilton tickets but
he doesn't have Hamilton tickets and he
doesn't have a way to get to it then
they're like the day of the show where
are my tickets I paid you for my tickets
and then he goes oh sorry meet me at
this corner whatever so then he shows up
with physical tickets that he just
bought and paid a ton of money for so he
lost money on the deal because he wanted
to give these people their tickets so
they wouldn't complain online and all
this stuff so he's losing money then
he's gonna buy tickets for something or
try to sell tickets for something else
to pay back that like he's just dumb
what's the deal with this fool does he
come from money yeah I don't think ja
rule got everything yet he's got his
problems away with it but he he has like
17 lawsuits I think still the fire yeah
I don't think he had a criminal thing
but he has civil lawsuit about investors
yeah investors lost out and also to all
the ticket buyers my brother ages and I
about the wanna comedy festival
well no young Ernie G promoting it a
flock will headline you perform in a
hologram
shut up to flock I could be the only
perfect performer the only comic living
who have a hologram
while he's living so this fool he's out
on bail right now make more money that
was the fire guy he's uh he's still
waiting they're not unbaling anymore
he's in jail
he got prosecuted and would again I
don't remember what the final charge was
or his sentence I mean a sentence in
does he have money stored away somewhere
I mean was it I mean trying I try to
like I said it's good to do crimes if
you get some money you get away with it
but I mean there has something's up with
this dude I mean never like a big old
thing in cash
[Music]
well stuff like oil you tell me to call
you before I'm calling you you're on the
podcast fool everybody is saying to call
you right now silly dog oh yeah I'll put
the volume of Berkeley you're talking
like you and the hospital unless you put
it to the mic here yeah man um I just
got out of surgery a couple of days ago
still recovering but I'm still in there
man still hanging in there good luck
guys fool you still there
are you there I know yeah they're here
is doc yeah it's just way too loud it's
what I'm saying what off we still there
yeah yeah I'm here oh oh my how you guys
doing well here doing a podcast brought
children cotton people say call you
everybody what's up fool or so far so
you ain't right now how you feeling
better
oh and that should good don't know those
our fundraiser that started by alpha
Robles last night a comedy show a little
bit with real I've gone towards a new
car a what how they're things no man
hope you doing better brother they were
asking me know everything which sounds
good yeah I'm trying to get back quick
man the better you perform I'm probably
on the phone for like to the end of the
year six months a year I still I lost
some leg I lost my name's basically
those of the foreign my legs but some of
my feet and cool baby I'm pleased the
matter okay something
however we love you bro can get better
yeah man I can't fly I like the large
thing what's up
who's that some guys I like those
thoughts and prayers to Flacco and
Rizzo's or be give you a cruiser had
Rizzo Hannah anywhere you know like a
[ __ ] yeah a quote sorry yeah where's
had a cold sore they live in it what you
there hello
yeah even here you couldn t hear us
oh yeah oh what's so fool all right dog
oh well yeah man looking forward to it
all right though take care of big dog
I was all right fool yeah I took a
picture that floats hurt but then a week
later I got one everybody go get Bob
whatever [ __ ] yeah
everybody go no seagulls on Instagram no
way you're right you're right [ __ ] I see
those are you go Twitter Flaco fever and
then on Instagram he's funny I used to
call my thing is like a menace yeah and
that's tough so he lost all the power in
his legs the strength in his legs that's
what he said gonna have to talk to
believe he he he beat the odds right
yeah most of those guys usually dying
when they're 30 my parents start by
these jokes really big that that gene
Simmons here I know watch our brush it
is you know you kiss songs it's like
five seconds
another fool like guitar fools are
really because like sing kitty you know
the other song that rocks Detroit Rock
City
the only one there the one I was singing
just now that that was more were there
that was singing but that was more of
their come back clean clean they're
clean and cuz aces it in the band
anymore yeah I want that do that to go
over for ace a while back he had a gold
cross UNK
oh you know that was a really that I
think I had stopped following her for a
long time and then that I missed that
part I heard there's a crazy story about
kisum dude there was a roadie told us
that kiss was on tour one time in the
drummer got sick dude so the drum tech
[ __ ] played the [ __ ] show and then
he was all tripping out how the [ __ ]
would a drum tech [ __ ] be able to
he's all you know he's probably a
drummer and [ __ ] what better way they
just put makeup on that [ __ ] the
Fox
yeah the [ __ ] saying this to you told me
about the father so I didn't even
believe you I was like what are you
talking about the Fox make it up see it
I I really thought he was making it up I
missed the Fox entirely I didn't even
know that part of his history history I
mean sorry no Jerry spit on oh crap
dudes lady
[Laughter]
I don't really know a lot too much about
kids just their students and [ __ ] man I
loved them when I was a kid but they're
just bubblegum it's not but a lot of
like I trip out a lot of guitar fools
are super into them for some reason that
dude the Vinny works for is all into him
all right Esther ku overslept ku ku ku
so cold just to email me
well she emailed you so I already go to
Esther coos page Esther ku ku k UK you
tell her wack we're gonna be stupid
why showing up where and I was
improperly so my sure oh really
they never I told gene Simmons and of
course tell him to your tongue the floor
dirty I guess the everything joke he
always says yeah I said no I saw Twitter
at the at the HBO party all the last
time you guys were at the premiere of
yeah I see you know one time at NAMM
full when he was doing the little beard
now know that I have shown Nashville is
that the [ __ ] guitar and [ __ ] drums
and all that [ __ ] at that I'm
Convention Center but it's when he was
doing that reality show so he had an
entourage and then people recorded
cameras and [ __ ] it was all like [ __ ]
he's all you know how he walks in his
face is all I exist loves being the
center of control the pain gene Simmons
Paul Stanley Ace Frehley
Peter Criss meaning Vincent Eric Carr at
the Fox Tommy Thayer Eric singer
Bruce Kulick and Derek who wakes up at
1:00 p.m.
[Laughter]
what's up with you bro bro comics if
you're waking everyone I think one that
when kids did their separate album loves
you that I had a feeling they were
looser not be together for a while yeah
nobody wind up Peter one huh that Weezer
album the Blue Album he has a song about
kids it's a he names all the dudes even
though even without Megan you could talk
he's had all the chicks huh he was the
ugliest one though without makeup
he was always my favorite maybe it's the
shape of this costume or something with
space-age nobody else's space he was
abroad BJ's hey thanks to be and our
summer camp we told about musical shows
and we put our musical shows and this
guy George the big kids are doing like
the lip-sync to the Beatles but there's
one fool I forgot his name he did the
[ __ ] kiss and they went all out bro
that puts out the Spitfire it's all of
not to but he's hearing a blood coming
out of him yeah and I think black black
he with his I know he was scary to me
when I was a kid too and they won the
kids cuz they were all badass and
everywhere around I judge copy that guys
costume for Halloween it's really yes
cardboard
oh my mom beat my ass I don't give a
[ __ ] thought I got a little bit of photo
we had and I put it around I mean I got
a piece of cardboard like and I could
really I mean a little guitar and I'm
just take that [ __ ] to a stick yes
straight period great super but then I
have the black pants didn't have a
[ __ ]
didn't amigo feel sad
you look like käptn kaos
like Johnny love that rody fool told us
the story about Kyocera he his his his
friends job was to prepare the limos
with the pools in after the show and
each one of those would have one the
band members with chicks in it
pools pools inside the limo dude like
hot tub they were nasty
yeah that's Norma's like oh no I mean
it's cool I guess you know if you're a
[ __ ] rock star [ __ ] but that's like
[Music]
what's the guy limp isn't it Fred how
like the only rocker I rely was shored
here was queen that's it
anybody I was short here get the [ __ ]
out of here man if you have a ball to
grow your hair long don't sing my queen
when Freddy cuz hair though there'd
sound
there you go it is by the way as I as a
super-huge queen fan and Freddie Mercury
pan I just saw the movie finally if you
want it we have the disk at home from
the SAG Awards but I was disappointed I
was highly disappointed for one he's
tight and short I thought it was over
exaggerated I think Freddie is 510 or
511 he's not short but yeah he was well
he is but trained in ballet so that's so
that's one thing I had a problem with
but the other thing was the timeline of
the music and like the Imagi you didn't
match and how they were saying nobody
knew who they were when I knew that they
had an album out that it was their third
album here it was sheer heart attack was
here pop very popular at that time when
they were talking about them doing Top
of the Pops I don't know what he was
talking about like little things like
that bugged me I just felt like they
weren't showing enough infighting before
it was like yes that's a great idea
let's do upper I was moving all about
Live Aid I thought that - no I know I
just found it in the but see that's a
documentary I think that queenie is a
documentary instead is he behind it yeah
I know Sasha Baron Cohen was supposed to
start at you and he owned the story I
think he would have been better - and
when I heard he was involved I was
excited but
like two years went by and it didn't
happen and it was kind of like the
Richard Pryor movie like getting rights
to things and it just felt yeah Jimi
Hendrix movie - with Andre 3000 which
actually was filmed I really wanted to
see that one - because he looked a lot
like to me and not just looking like am
I good you know it's the whole thing
with with Queen I was so excited about
it and disappointed anyway what's up boo
what's up everybody up Esther ku
couldn't make it she fell asleep she
slept she slept cool late catching up on
her sleep in Visalia February 1st
prosecutor the porn Awards Coachella we
saw you gotta sit through bad speeches
and probably do like red carpet
interviews and stuff to like cry because
you got the award for best ain't no like
the way I'm goofy comedy well you want
to think my mom would kick you out of
the house when I was 12
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm watching it for the sixth time yeah
you know the best I think the best rock
documentary is still some kind of
monster I think that's my favorite I
never liked me no me neither
I can't stand it I didn't like him till
I seen him live but uh cuz the drummer's
off indistinct out the talent I'm gonna
take over the world
yeah I but I never liked Metallica and
the player yeah but they did it honest -
and they don't hide the they don't hide
the ugly fights that they hadn't which I
liked but uh that and then the [ __ ]
manager Spang galley guy coming in and
controlling everything and trying to get
involved then he starts giving like a
baseline or when they were gonna fire
that fool yeah hey guys like you got old
man
like he thought the band was dumb like
he was actually controlling them and
they yeah snapped out of it they
remembered oh yeah we pay this guy
cuckoo cuckoo clock what's up fool don't
forget man I'm coming to Birmingham
Alabama February 15 through 17 at the
stardome Raleigh North Carolina at the
Raleigh improv February 22nd through the
24th Miami Florida get ready
--kavitha I'm coming back you got some
rice and beans only in the coffee every
morning large 8th to the 10th improv
also shout-out to that guy who gave me
those cigars forgot your name and sugar
instead uh nicaragua nicaraguan on and
on on it's ruined for Maryland and
shout-out to a guy who gave me those don
marco coffee Don Francisco Francisco
copy can't wait to taste that right yeah
but Don Francisco the TV guy right ok
Motley Crue versus a dozen roses I don't
know I like Malik Rubidoux they came for
myself too fast for love is a [ __ ]
masterpiece bro you what see I hate it I
hated anything after they did the [ __ ]
sweet child of mine thing and then I
hated that I Alex that Axl Rose thought
he was a singer that's what I hated oh
and I felt like in that one his drama
really comes out I reckon song I think
he wrote the lyrics like a high school
girl is a high school girl lyrics
what's the name of the drummer Adler
I heard of my Howard Stern I founded a
book on iBooks narration no I read it
actually oh you ready it is hardcore he
he gets into it Cindy Jo ho when you're
working at that at that nightclub when
he was a kid like high school kid was
long here in the valley always party the
party [ __ ] dude hit a hairy chest
like 14 Doug he said that he got
molested brought by these two promoter
and Hollywood over and over they party
too much they say right now that that
fool has a band and he actually plays
the first record from construction
wasn't he was he kicked out as a kid
kicked out of his house and his thing
him and him it wasn't him or pal before
they met Axl slash slash but he was like
neglected at one add some ancient at
some point right yeah that's what it was
grandma or so yeah that was crazy
no wonder what he says about how uh when
he went out you bet when he went out
loud how Axl Rose had a hold out and I
gave him his money and his wife who
wouldn't cut the money back he actually
sued him and got yeah things about how
Axl Rose was David Boies for the good
shows that they were gonna do a show in
New York that was free or some concert
and then they were all there and he
didn't show up so they didn't do the
show there the next day they had a show
on TV or somewhere and he was all better
again so he will stay with Boyd for the
good shakers you can be screaming like a
[ __ ] open up honey hole that's what
I'm saying like he's not a good singer
technically he seems wrong he sings the
wrong way so he's gonna give himself
nodes on this vocal cords screaming like
that
Bryan Johnson did the same thing and
Bryan Johnson didn't have the same voice
that Bon Scott had no no way I mean bon
Scott's voice was really a gravel soaked
raspy voice naturally when Johnson turns
on screaming like that and then he ended
up with notes on his vocal cords he
can't perform any rocket queen they're
badass I don't really agree with that
that first one but you know whose book I
read this badass the slashes book yeah
but Molly crew the dirt but Molly crew
the dirt the first edition of that when
it came out again or in paperback they
Nikki rewrote a lot of that stuff a lot
of right I had it and it tore apart it
was a good they toned it down or did
different out of the third I don't know
why little bit but he talks about the
what six-day binge that he did with
vanity and that was in detail detail and
how they were hallucinating and they
were like paranoid and yeah and they
locked themselves into the room so they
wouldn't get hurt while they were coming
down it was weird
they injected everything he's injected
everything into his body at some point
just to try and see if it works to get
him high our dog how squishy she went to
was like I feel like Lisa is prejudiced
toward glam-rock
why did I never said I didn't like
Cinderella
that's I didn't reset I was prejudiced
for glam-rock
and I wouldn't consider Motley Crue glam
rock there yeah I well I'd say glam rock
would be David Bowie that glam rock
would be t-rex glam rock would be
Cinderella
toto maybe Cinderella being there I
guess hair bands
let's hairband glam-rock steerer
original glam run with more Pankaj knows
before that I'd say late set I'd say it
ended with New York Dolls that was
that's the end of glam rock but David
Bowie started it that whole and Joe
Jonas then Queen wouldn't be considered
glam rock I think anybody any man who
wore makeup and was androgynous you know
man Joey
I wouldn't consider Guns and Roses glam
rock their hair down their hair band and
it's a badass story in that book dog
slashes book they like he's half black
right and his mom's from South Central
his dad's from England and that fool
from I think it's wife Dickey lawless
black flash yeah most ly just telling
the story they Duff McKagan was chilling
and that dude said lukela
Jackie libellus he told he told / and /
ran over there and that full ran away
though he deny any of those black guys
who knows they were doing together with
that guy from Ally guns with mark well
what's the name was uh that's why it's
good ally guns used to be yeah Axl Rose
heads open icon Axl Rose right no well
he wasn't la guns and a gun part of that
name but they were later get in a van
and the BAM broke down and I gave him a
Lee does his [ __ ] did our money here
that stories and it wouldn't they kept
going and he was when he got to the
shore though [ __ ] the work Guns N'Roses
but the guy was Izzy Stradlin also in
gun in LA guns yeah yeah he's the Ridgid
he's the first one to drop I love thee
struggling he's my favorite
he was my favorite he was the skinniest
guy I've ever seen just [ __ ] they
were knocking back two bottles of
[ __ ] Jack Daniels raw dog no Coke or
nothing no the stray he never mentioned
I'm actually a [ __ ] up on the book I
think he did he had like excellent Donna
here I felt like these two were the room
crew and actually his own crew outside
of my way they make it look as but he
reacts will always had the fame the
desire for fame and being that Rockstar
lead guy he I think alcohol was his
choice of drug for most of the time and
I don't think he went as deep as the
other guys and an axle yeah he had his
sights on Fame so that's that was all
that was important how many fools just
like him afterwards bro everybody dog
but if you notice them they were on the
first video and Jerry pointed this out
he thought they were glam and then the
the next video they were all just like
bikers and [ __ ] yeah well maybe Axl Rose
did have some makeup on and welcome to
the jungle huh he did have some eyeliner
on your right
I never thought on that way but there's
a bad asset you can get on YouTube where
they're playing uh I want to say it's a
Roxy or maybe the whiskey they were
perfect there is an old photo of them
they used to go to Canter's and eat
after they rehearsed his body wrote a
book because a photo agencies are in the
kibitz room I saw Ali I saw her golden
rule in 1980 at the Olive Street scene I
was I don't know who they were but that
guy would play that song go this is
dedicated to here he was he played that
song for the cops
half-line know we had that that uh that
song that would an take up who I'm gonna
roll this I say did a cover of something
cuz I knew [ __ ] there's a picture of
him and Ice Cube and him and he said
this go for these [ __ ]
I saw Axelrod stock dozen roses of a
band with a bunch of a [ __ ] drum
renegade a Stryper Stryper you see when
you can't see another bit anything else
is so that way a striper tickets people
wonder what performing on though under
watch it called and the City Hall stairs
you know Stevie Wonder performing there
but I would like to million people to
get there really yeah supposed to go
over there to the rock it was less less
people do you want to have everybody and
they have a drink you perform there
ladies and gentlemen is the bigger boys
storm I read from Frankenstein George
Clinton does it call dr. Funkenstein dr.
funk
that was one of his food website this
okay Charlotte everybody here German
does Hector wait let's go back to the
beginning because there's a guy from
England here I want to go to show it
hello mate
how the price chips the chips German
sick
Rico Sanjay German auto be beyond o-over
Gonzalez Dan Estrada Bugsy SG be at the
little baby
Charlie nacho nacho man I wanna eat some
nachos man Flacco's tacos first they are
as far as the 1980 my boyfriend has a
different story about how actually got
his name okay we're at my Axl Rose and
what the bad was the roses by the way
nonsense to large said he doesn't
remember none of these artists we are
old first of all but its artists aren't
that all I like the large looks like now
I think I've told you we're driving home
from Turlock I tell you there was a
photo of my dad off yeah with his friend
with the hubcap on it yeah looks like
your dad finding his friend my friend
dad my dad [ __ ] up right but there
aren't you gonna fall other drink is
where I work
and my dad's a tank top but his friend
had a tank top and you can tell he was
trying to be funny
so he puts a hub
okay.what so oh we did have what's up
fool on a beanie but they sold out and
we don't make anymore
we have out [ __ ] I won't [ __ ] you don't
have a hat we should get some more be
nice with the new logo but sewn on I'll
do that for winter next year with a
patch next yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go
alright everybody bad boy we can't stay
here no more have wonderful rest of the
week